[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
all right hey everyone
[Applause]
all right welcome to Sparks Nevada uh
set of the Tesla gigafactory and our
Tesla semi truck Factory as well so uh
yeah I can't believe it's been five
years
um
so we unveiled the Tesla semi uh five
years ago
um it's been a lot that's happened since
then say the least
um so we were incredibly excited tonight
to actually deliver our first production
Tesla semi trucks
okay
so and it's right next door to the uh
Giga Nevada
our Giga Factory here which produces the
uh most number of battery cells in North
America it produces our drive units and
battery packs
and uh yeah so I'd like to start off by
giving a big hand to the Tesla
gigafactory team and the Tesla semi
truck team it's like
oh
[Applause]
so I and I think you've had a chance to
tour the production line so cool right
um and uh yeah we're looking forward to
actually delivering our first production
trucks to uh PepsiCo so this is going to
be fantastic
[Applause]
yeah and also a huge thank you to all of
our other customers I mean A lot's
happened in the last five years and our
customers have been super loyal and
supportive and you know stuck with us
and been a huge part of our development
and we're excited to show everything
that we've been doing off to everybody
tonight
great so let's get started
yeah so
yeah sorry for the delay um
so it's been like sheer number sure
amount of drama between this Elizabeth
that five years ago and now is insane
um a lot has happened in the world
but uh here we are Israel so
yeah we threw a great party a few few
years back and uh trying to do a similar
thing here tonight and you know Tesla's
been growing like crazy I mean you know
everybody here has been you know
contributing towards the growth and
unveiling awesome products and really
scaling us to the point that now we can
actually work on semi and we're really
excited to do that but we've been
working a little bit on the background
close to the chest you know right level
of priority but you know made a lot of
progress incorporate a lot of things
that we're going to talk about and at
the end of the day we have not wavered
from our mission to build the most
compelling greatest Class 8 truck in
history so we're going to keep putting
our foot forward to do that and yeah
it's uh it's pretty awesome
foreign
because if you look at the actual unit
volume it's it's small compared to
passenger vehicles so for passenger
vehicles you know this on the order of
uh almost 100 million that are sold
every year and whereas if semi trucks
it's uh like for four or five hundred
thousand not even yet it's a couple
hundred thousand classic trucks a year
globally yeah yeah or no no sorry that's
us yeah yeah so it's it's so this in the
so the US is quoted like 15 million
passenger vehicles and a couple hundred
thousand semi trucks so it seems like a
small percentage but uh it's actually 20
percent of U.S vehicle emissions because
you've got a huge vehicle and it's being
driven uh all the time so when you
factor in the number of hours driven and
the weight that it's carrying it's
actually although it's only one percent
of vehicle production it's 20 of vehicle
emissions and it's over a third of all
the articulate emissions so from a sort
of Health standpoint particularly in
like cities this is a huge impact like
gigantic so
um that's why we're doing it you know so
yeah
yeah this is this is really core to our
mission and you have to deal on this
point there's a lot of heavy trucks that
are deployed in dense urban areas and so
the communities that are around freeways
a lot of where these trucks are
domiciled are going to really benefit
particularly from the particular
emissions reductions and then you know
just trying to reduce emissions globally
every truck that we put on the road that
replaces a diesel truck is a huge amount
of Leverage and so that's that is why
we're doing this and makes a huge
difference towards driving us towards
our total mission of sustainable energy
and transportation yeah I think maybe a
lot of people don't realize it's
actually like you know quite unhealthy
to be living next to a highway with with
diesel trucks FYI so
um
so being able to make them electric is
just going to be uh just in addition to
sort of
climate change and and uh global warming
matters
um it's also quiet and it's it's going
to improve the quality of your air and
it will actually just fundamentally
improve the health of people living near
freeways which is obviously a super big
deal so if anybody's been woken up at a
noisy truck delivering in the morning
you know the quiet will definitely be
very welcome I know I will appreciate
that yeah so
um so we're aiming to cover all the all
major forms of Transport uh it's just
consistent with the Tesla Mission
because sometimes they get asked like
well you know shouldn't Tesla just
produced like
uh you know fast cars or or premium cars
or whatever it's like but but what's our
actual Mission our actual mission is to
accelerate the Advent of sustainable
energy so
um that's why we're making this wide
range of cars that don't really make
sense from a brand standpoint I guess
traditionally but they make total sense
when you consider what's the mission of
the company missions company is to
accelerate sustainable energy and so
it's it's super consistent with that
goal
um and uh really a crucial piece of the
puzzle and and that's why we're doing it
yeah and I mean Elon you first laid this
out in master plan part dough and you
know now we're here to actually make it
happen and you know everything from the
mission side along with reducing the
cost of cargo transport and also make it
fun I mean we want to make the truck an
awesome Driving Experience you know make
a kick ass for the drivers yeah I mean
it looks sick
[Music]
oh
[Music]
I mean you want to drive that I mean
that thing looks like it came from the
future it I mean it drives like a like
it's like driving a you know a Tesla
literally
um it's fun it looks awesome and you
know there's there's actually a big
shortage of drivers and so if you're a
truck driver and you want the most
badass rig on the road this is it
so
yeah that's it it's a beast
um
so uh
you know at Tesla we don't make slow
cars uh we don't make this this thing
has crazy power relative to a diesel
truck I mean actually especially if you
if you don't have if you're not towing
anything you could zip around like it
looks crazy basically it looks like a
elephant moving like a cheetah it
doesn't look right correctly
um but it's uh it's this isn't this is
not sluggish in the least it's it's fast
uh it's fast to accelerate it's it's uh
fast to break it's really a step change
Improvement and uh what it's like to
drive a semi truck
um yeah we've got three times the power
three times the power
than any diesel truck on the road right
now so you got all the work all the
power you need to get the job done but
the other reason that it's a beast is
because it's also efficient and you can
go 500 miles on a single charge on one
of these things so it's the mix of those
two that this is why this is a game
changer and what's awesome is both of
those are enabled by our new thousand
volt powertrain which is the first
vehicle that we're doing with that and
don't worry there'll be some more things
more vehicles coming with that but uh
this is going to be a game changer
because of all the awesome innovations
that have happened you know behind the
scenes and you know under the hood so to
speak
cool
yeah so we're obviously leveraging
leveraging a ton of stuff that we've
already done so we've got uh well it's
not probably 51 billion miles driven I
don't know because more every every day
um so we're using our existing drive
units Power Electronics uh infotainment
that are super efficient uh heat pump
HVAC system uh and uh state of the art
inverters so we're able to leverage uh
the existing powertrain and elements
that are already made at volume in order
to
achieve extreme efficiency of cost and
capability yeah and it also means we get
to leverage all the reliability that the
active car Fleet is doing so we're
accumulating all these miles getting a
ton of demonstrated learnings into the
field and we're going to go and put all
these trucks into the world and get a
lot of learnings as well but we're
coming off of a great launching pad with
everything that's done and the rest of
our products already and it's also
enabled because you know Tesla's got
this full vertical integration on the
software and the hardware side so the
teams that are working together to put
all that together into one package this
is a huge win you know for all of our
products but particularly semi
lots of Hardcore testing so I mean one
thing is about a commercial truck is
that the reliability has to be extremely
high so it's going to got to be running
continuously can't break down it's going
to handle every kind of weather uptime
is is super important for any kind of
semi truck so we've tested durability in
every kind of weather every kind of
environment
um I mean you could yeah yeah I mean we
so even just we've driven Donner we'll
talk a little bit more about that in a
moment but we've been through hot cold
snow rain we've been putting this thing
through all its Paces in the lab as well
as in the real world the simulation team
has been doing an incredible job of
being able to scale all of that you know
in the virtual side and the other thing
is that we're going to take these we're
going to put our money where our mouth
is and we're going to put these on into
our own Fleet into our own supply chain
and we're going to use this to transport
goods between our factories and our
suppliers because we believe in it not
just from a mission perspective and a
cost perspective but because we want to
close that feedback loop we got to get
that learning as fast as we can we want
it straight from the drivers went
straight from the service techs that are
working on it we're going to take all
that data that's coming in and continue
to find the product to make it better
just like we do on the car side
yeah exactly so to be clear like these
semi trucks are running 24 7 between uh
Sparks uh
technically in Sparks not Reno but most
people think of it as Reno Reno's box uh
and Tahoe and uh
yeah this is technically the uh called
the Tahoe Reno industrial complex or
Trek
um
now there's an interesting backstory
about why it's called that fairy yeah
so
um anyway it's it's the the
Tesla using the trucks continuously day
and night uh between
um here and Fremont and back again
is going to be it is a great test of the
vehicle and will give us a great
feedback loop for continuing to improve
the product
so my click is sort of not working there
we go all right so yeah um we've got a
tri-motor uh powertrain system so and
they're we're using the coffin over wrap
sleeve so essentially we're using the
The Plaid uh Model S model X powertrain
uh and um but it would work and actually
enabling the
two of the drive units to actually
disconnect uh so that they're not uh
free spinning so the efficiency is
actually much greater in Cruise yeah
this is really unique I mean we're going
with the tri-motor system one of them is
constantly engaged so that's for maximum
efficiency you're getting on a highway
that's doing the bulk of the work and
it's operating at the peak efficiency
point of the entire drivetrain and then
the other two units are for torque and
acceleration so when the driver needs it
to get their job done whether that's you
know getting out of a loading dock or
it's on the road they need to pass
somebody you're tackling a grade you
have the torque and power to do it and
the cool thing is that these are
clutched automatically so no driver
input needed but it's also seamless so
the highway efficiency unit is cruising
along doing its thing and if the driver
puts their foot to the floor the torque
units spin up clutch engages and takes
over and it does all of that before
we've maxed out the torque on the
efficiency unit so it's completely
smooth there's no turbo lag or jerkiness
or anything like that no driver input
needed it's smooth both in terms of
acceleration and deceleration for Regen
it's uh really cool happening all behind
the scenes yeah I mean what I find
actually really wild about this is that
uh you can have a truck which is 82 000
pounds and by the way the reason we can
actually do 82 000 pounds is that
there's a 2 000 pound extra uh that's
allowed by law for electric trucks so
you get a little bit of a advantage on
the uh on the on the wait side
um but you can you can basically pull 82
000 pounds uh on at Cruise using and the
only thing that's doing that is a tiny
little motor on one axle oh that big
about a football side maybe yeah you can
carry it yeah like it's like a you know
I mean you can check it in your luggage
good luck about doing that with a diesel
engine and one of those is more powerful
than a diesel yeah yeah just that just
that one little guy is but it's more
powerful than a regular diesel engine on
a on a semi truck
um but it's just I find it like amazing
that this enormous thing can be pulled
by something that you could carry in
your hands
it's like wow that's power density yep
[Music]
[Applause]
so yeah and then in terms of you know
we're putting this to use in the real
world
[Applause]
[Music]
so that that truck's clocking in at 82.
that's weighing 82 000 pounds and when
you see that pass shot again
you'll notice
you'll notice that speedometer is
climbing you know we're going six
percent and accelerating up that grade
this is yeah this is where it comes in
yeah it's really it's it's like driving
a normal car not like driving a truck
um it's just that you're you're moving
82 000 pounds yeah um yeah so any
Highway grade you come across you can
tackle at speed yeah there's no
compromise no slow down nope and the
other beauty is that you've got all this
power going up but you also have it
going down and what that means is you've
got regenerative braking so rather than
using a jake brake or engine braking
like a diesel truck does where you have
to worry about hitting your shifts if
you miss a gear you're onto your brakes
and potentially in a Runway situation
you don't have to worry about any of
that there's no shifting no nothing and
so the regen recaptures all that energy
as you're going down these grades but on
top of it it also is a safer system for
not just the driver but everybody on the
road because there's no gear to miss
I mean just it's worth re-emphasizing
that point
um because it's an electric uh
drivetrain when it goes downhill you
actually or when you slow down it
recaptures the energy of motion or the
energy of of of of height the potential
kinetic energy are largely recaptured uh
whereas for a diesel truck that's not
possible you can't just you know create
diesel so it you just end up hitting
brakes and and then your brakes overheat
and you can't use them and then it's
actually quite it's pretty dangerous
because you the brakes stop working yeah
that's why you have runaway truck ramps
yeah yeah and it's funny because so if
for any of you that have driven I-80 and
driven Donner there's a mandatory brake
check stop for trucks down by immigrant
Gap we've done this and it's really
funny because we'll go over the grade
we'll come down and we just kind of pull
it aside and like well there's nothing
to check we've never used the things and
we just keep driving yeah yeah and we
get to the bottom of the hill we have
cold breaks yeah that's like
mind-blowing in the trucking world so
it's like insane basically and you can't
so
[Applause]
so it's really worth emphasizing that
that's a significant safety Improvement
for the truck driver and for other
people on the road
um and and the we also have um excellent
traction control because the Precision
of an electric motor is vastly better
than a diesel engine
um you know it's sort of got like the
I'm trying to think of the
right analogy here but like it's got the
Precision of like a laser printer it's
not great it's like really precise
that's what I'm saying
um and and the reaction is uh so it's
like you don't have to worry about uh
like traction control is awesome it's
got uh it's automatically stopping the
the truck from jackknifing it's doing
all this safety stuff in the background
that just isn't possible with uh regular
diesel trucks it's just it's it's a step
change in technology in in in so many
ways
um yeah and the tight integration with
the software team that we have here
really makes that happen because it
means that we could take all that uh the
Precision and actually put it to use you
know it's not some tie-in of some
third-party powertrain no this is all
in-house as we do this really neat uh
you know chassis control work at the
brake level the traction control level
we integrate with our uh total stability
control system and make sure that the
driver you know has a lot of confidence
but also has everything you need to stay
on the road it's going to be it's a
really nice neat integrated uh package
overall in terms of you know software
and control and it's totally seamless to
the driver and it'll be a game changer
in terms of safety yeah
yeah
so we talked power you want to talk
efficiency yeah absolutely
um so you know some people out there say
it can't be done
um I don't know who might say that but
I've heard rumors
um
and uh so we just did it
um
yeah
and we're going to post the whole video
unedited on YouTube yeah and uh no jump
Cuts yeah and this wasn't you know some
Ultra Clean precise test track
simulation or something where we you
know shut down a road nope this is real
world you know this is over Grapevine
this is with traffic this is true 500
miles you know we were loaded just under
82k
you know we didn't no special Arrow
treatments yeah came off the line shook
it down made it run that's it yeah it
was like no fast moves here that would
be clear it's not like oh and what what
did what tricks do they pull were there
actually a whole bunch of Tricks we
could have pulled yeah
uh uh so uh you know like as Dan said
like no special Arrow treatment uh the
oh and by the way we should mention
there was no charging like we charged it
yeah okay we didn't stop the charge
single single driver exactly yeah yeah
good point um so minor yeah yeah so it's
not like 500 Miles like with no load
with special arrow and special
everything it's like fully loaded going
from the Bay Area we actually had to
like go up at North to get to you know
actually add to get to 500 Miles because
you can you know L.A know the Bay Area
is less than that well we went all the
way to San Diego here so yeah we
stressed out on the southern end and uh
I mean do you want to see on the video I
mean yeah we have the proof absolutely
so
it's only eight hours long so yeah block
of land
don't worry we brought lots of snacks
yeah
standard trip
down the five up great fine through LA
traffic construction you know we got the
bypass on the weight station but you
know running full 80 or just under 82
full deliveries nothing to hide yeah
yeah
yeah real world it's yeah you did take
one restroom break for there there is a
required mandatory 30-minute break
within the first eight hours of
operation took a small restroom break
but that was it yep all right
cool
[Applause]
so aerodynamic efficiency obviously
matters a lot you can see it's it's a
shaped like a bullet it's really
aerodynamic
um and uh that that helps a lot as we
get to less than two kilowatt uh hours
two kilowatt hours a mile yep so and
that's the name of the game is
efficiency there yep yep so uh
yeah I mean it's really efficient uh in
every way and uh I mean the team's done
a lot of awesome work I mean because we
went to the wind tunnel um with this
really cool model Rolling Road the whole
nine yards and pulled in a lot of
learnings at all of our features from
the car side that you know give us such
great real world efficiency there and
really want to make sure that the you
know the truck and the trailer have to
work together you know this is a
combination this is not just the truck
if you optimize one you actually might
disrupt the whole combination and so we
spent a lot of time both you know
virtually but also in the wind tunnel to
make this happen and really some Next
Level engineering to uh of everything
they had to do there and you know it
means that we've got a really efficient
truck
as I said it's as easy to drive as a
model three because like uh like with
basically no training you can drive this
um who knows
you have to think bigger when you're
driving it but it's not like it's not
hard to drive it's really easy and we
put the center it put the seat in the
center for Max visibility low floor you
can stand up in the cabin yeah that's
actually like a really big deal I mean I
mean your tall guy Elon like you're able
to stand up just fine and you know nice
thing is is that if you're a truck
driver and you're out during the day
it's you know it's cold it's snowy
whatever you can get in and this isn't a
sleeper cab this is a day cab you can
still stand up and you can shed your
jacket put it on the wall all in the
comfort you can put your coveralls on
while in the cab so if you have to go do
a dirty job you can do that comfortably
as opposed to being out in the elements
so that's you know that level of space
is you know unheard of we were able to
do that with some pretty Innovative
packaging and on top of it there's
plenty of cargo storage you know for
drivers need to bring any tools other
equipment along and not to mention you
know we've got the plugins the wireless
charging everything they need on the
electronic side as well yep
yeah so I've got efficiency in every
aspect of the vehicle I've got one touch
a suspension dump so it's very easy to
attach to the trailer it saves time and
money it's uh the fleet's more efficient
the driver's home sooner yeah I mean
really if we're trying to extend the
idea of this efficiency from not just
while you're on the road but into the
yard as well that's before and after you
know the truck has done its job on the
road because that means that you know
drivers at the end of the day are
spending less time at the yard and
they're getting home earlier it makes
their lives easier you know we've got a
light test that's easy to execute helps
with compliance there's all these little
things that the design team really spent
their time you know researching they did
ride-alongs they studied they did all
this work it was really cool to watch
the put I mean I think they even took
like a bunch of like the various cups
and put them in CAD and you'll see them
like put them in various cup holder
sizes and places they'll like mock up a
bag they'll do all kinds of neat stuff
to understand how a driver Works
throughout the day and it means they'll
have a more efficient experience overall
obviously to charge a truck like this
quickly you need high power chargers so
we developed a megawatt class charger as
it's capable of charging at megawatt to
DC yeah and it's our next Generation
immersive cooling so it's liquid cooled
so you don't need like a gigantic
elephant trunk of a cable you can
actually have a small small cable and
that cable delivers a megawatt
um and uh yeah with 3x the current
density I mean this is really cool stuff
I mean
we took you're actually immersing the
conductor in the coolant this
water-based coolant that we have and
we're then doing some really neat
isolation monitoring on the back end to
ensure that it's safe in delivering that
it needs to but it means that we can
really shove a lot of current in a very
very small place so you know for those
that have worked uh and charged their
cars on a V3 supercharger and the cable
is nice and you know maneuverable it's
the same thing here but now we're just
shoving a megawatt through it instead so
you know this is key for high power
applications like semi but
you want to tell him or do you want me
to tell him
yeah I mean it's going to be used for
cyber truck too yeah
so this is this is coming to our
superchargers uh next year yeah
so the future of Transport obviously
requires a sustainable energy
infrastructure so you got to have all
aspects of the
the energy question answered sustainable
power generation then you've got to
store the power and then you transfer
the power to the vehicle so like the
three pillars of a sustainable energy
future are sustainable power generation
with solar and wind I'm actually a fan
of nuclear
um
which we should support
um and and uh geothermal and many others
but things that are sustainable uh long
term we we uh but but things like wind
and solar intermittent so you have to
have the battery pack to store the
energy so when the wind doesn't blowing
the sun doesn't shine you still have
energy and you can also buffer the power
so you're not overloading the grid with
Spike loads yeah and our semi customers
are actively deploying this today and
we're working with them so that they
have the pathway to get towards you know
100 sustainable future you know but we
have all of this at our disposal you
know commercial solar and mega pack and
you know the mega pack is great because
not only can it do things like Peak
shaving or some of the other uh energy
modulation but it also provides a form
of redundancy and backup I mean if we're
going to ask you know a fleet to take on
these trucks and run them they need to
ensure that they're gonna be able to
charge them and keep their Fleet running
and even the amount of power outage and
that's one of the things that we can do
with the mega pack on site as well
all right
so and post deliveries are now yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I would just like to to thank PepsiCo
they've been a great partner
hey guys
hey how's it going
hey let's go
um
so yeah we completed our first cargo run
with a very enormous amount of Frito
Lays uh which I'm sure we have a lot of
them here yeah
all right
and uh yesterday we were actually able
to complete our first delivery
compliments of Frito-Lay we took a truck
down to their Modesto Factory from here
and one of their drivers we delivered
the truck they took it over and they
brought back a load of snacks for
everybody here to enjoy tonight
[Applause]
yep
so big thanks to Kirk and Stephen yeah
do you guys would you guys want to say
anything yeah
yeah nothing like this happens without
amazing people and so I just want to
thank the people that spent countless
hours to make this a reality that's it
the people
that that's it I I just want to Echo I
know a lot of work went into it and this
is fantastic we're thrilled uh about the
delivery today so thank you yeah thanks
for letting us be a part of this thank
you so much appreciate you thank you
yeah thank you Dan
[Applause]
hahaha
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
all right so um yeah thank you all thank
you all for coming uh it's it's been a
long long journey a long five years uh
but uh This is Gonna really
revolutionize the roads and I think make
the world a better place and in a
meaningful way
um so thank you for your support through
all the years
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]